how did you like the keynote uh it was
it was very interesting so I've never
yeah seen uh Professor Hinton before it
was raised the discussion and it's
discussion that's important for sort of
the field to have um there are a lot of
words that have different meanings
between you know apparently different
camps a lot of them that have strong
feelings about their meaning that's
specifically towards the first part of
his talk when he was talking about do
llms understand really given the
definition of understanding that he was
sort of outlining but it's not complete
it's just a spectrum and then might
understand some things but they don't
understand a lot of things but I haven't
really looked into the philosophy of
both sides